trash Sher but I don't really talk
trash just facts now the best trash
shocker I I would I would go with
somebody like yoke or Luca like Luca
Just Smiles like that's so disrespectful
like you're not going to just hit a post
fade behind the backboard and laugh at
me and what look little boy little
boy I want to have great handle speed
with balls and musts I'm pretty good at
Naturally defending I just like to have
steel to you know be able to have glove
or Interceptor at least cross over I
think I like Zach's put the jumper on
and we're good I think I had bogey Kobe
this is uh my jump shot you guys can
steal it if you want tell I play a
lot congratulations I appreciate it Be A
Champion yes sir it's nice once you get
it it's relieving but you can't be
content you know there's teams gearing
up to try to beat you so we can't think
about last year and how great last year
was you know we got to try to repeat
[Music]
it